good day everyone I'm Jack Van Horn from
the mark and Mary Stevens new imaging
and informatics Institute at the
University of Southern California home
of the bd2k training coordinating center
and let me welcome you to the big data
to knowledge guide to the fundamentals
of data science we're very excited this
morning to have Gustavo Guzman from the
Institute for systems biology discussing
his work on genomic fingerprinting and
representation Gustavo is a principal
scientist at the Institute for systems
biology in Seattle Washington where he
uses computational approaches to
investigate genome structure its
functioning evolution as well as the
genetics of disease he's developed a
number of novel algorithms for
discovering genes which are not easily
identifiable by a standard procedures
and for the interpretation of
large-scale transcriptomics and genomic
data and for the analysis modeling
visualization of this complex data he's
going to be discussing today some of his
work on genomic fingerprinting and
representation and what that means in
the context of the study of disease as
well as normal human function and we're
very excited to have him I'd like to
remind the audience that they can submit
any questions they have for dr. Guzman
by using the questions submission system
there and the GoToWebinar a little box
that's on the right side of your screen
and we will look at those and I'll ask
those on your behalf closer to the top
of the hour without further ado I'd very
much like to invite Gustavo to take the
stage and to tell us about genomic
fingerprinting and representation
Gustavo the stage is yours Thank You
Chuck good morning to everybody so yes
I'm very excited to talk today about our
method for living genome fingerprints
and I would like to cover this topics
why we need them how they work various
characteristics that they have they're
quite important to understand what they
enable us to do and then finally I want
to give a little bit of a teaser of what
comes next new methods were developing
so to start with the idea of why we
needed to know fingerprints they want to
throw us back to 1995 when I was
studying a factor receptor gene
at the Weizmann Institute of Science in
Israel and one day I was analyzing this
small chunk of genomic sequence from the
human genome in the middle of the
cluster four factor receptor genes and
doing all this analysis manually and
annotating the sequence in you know the
the best detail that we can do at the
time and then looking at this sequence I
realize here that this is one millionth
of a human genome so that pretty much
gave me the sense of the scale of the
human genome how complex it is how large
it is and just this idea that one day
you would be able to look at every
single bit of a human genome maybe in
this level of detail and what kind of
vistas would we get from that
so another was kind of our wall
speculation of the day and we were
having group meeting there and somebody
brought up this idea for imagine
somebody or to enter the room give us a
hard drive including the complete
finished sequence of the human genome
what we do with it I mean back then it
was really really kind of a big leap of
imagination to think what what all the
different things one could do with the
genome to kind of even the main idea was
you know we would like to compare every
single bit of the genome with every
other single bit of a genome would be
massive computational challenge of
course fast forward a few years after
that by 2003 and 70 we definitely indeed
had the whole genome and nowadays one
can easily do something like this to
take the entire genome sequence the
reference genome as we call it now and
create a map so this is a visualization
of the entire human genome showing all
kinds of characteristics that are
important like a GC content where the
genes are located locations and types of
interspersed repeats all kinds of
remaining problems with a reference and
gaps etc etc and again this is a map map
of our basic biology human genome and
this enables doing many many things and
just like with any map it can help you
find your way around the genome identify
where things
located and chart your course but one of
the most important things that this
reference genome map allows us to do is
if you think about the cost that they
talk to the cost and the effort to
sequence out original reference genome
of the human species now we can actually
use this map to sequence individual
genomes
so essentially instead of sequencing a
new person the genome of the person from
scratch we can simply obtain the DNA
from the sample and do it whole lot of
sequencing of short reads and that is
typically represented in this fast queue
files would represent both the sequence
and the quality of each read and then we
can use again this reference genome to
align all those reads to a reference
it's kind of a very very significant
shortcut instead of having to do the
novo assembly and once we align all
those reads to the reference we
typically represent that in using this
so-called bam format which shows the
alignment of all those reads to the
reference once we have those fries
aligned to the reference and then the
next step is to determine which genome
variants there are relative to a
reference or as called to call the
variants and the most common format for
representing a person's genome after
doing that for encoding is the VCF or
the variant call format and as you can
see here from this tiny synopsis use all
kinds of headers and then there is a
whole series of statements let's say on
which chromosome at which position in
the chromosome what is the reference
allele what are the alternate alleles
then there are statements about quality
and all kinds of additional info
information about the variant but most
importantly then there is a step in the
world
what is the genotype of a person at that
specific variant and a typical human
will be a human genome will be
represented in a VCF file with roughly
in the order of 3 to 4 million such
statements so that is a very significant
simplification if you wish of
the entire process of going from a
sample of a person of the person's DNA
to the actual statements about what
their genome looks like so this is kind
of the very basic ideas of how to
represent genome data so reality is we
never actually got the reference genome
in a hard drive because it was already
possible to download it directly from
the internet but this ability to
sequence individual genomes actually led
us to the point where we actually did
start getting genomes in hard drives
courses for genomes of individuals and
the first study that we did using whole
genome sequence data from individuals
was his analysis of the family quartet
in which both children are affected when
Baylor syndrome and the two parents are
unaffected and we obtained the sequence
for all four people in the family and we
had to develop a whole series of basic
concepts and algorithms to analyze the
sequence of the complete genome with all
the common variants and the rare
variants and all kinds of structural
variants as well and to go from the
whole genome of these four people to a
very very short list of four candidate
genes and actually the story there was
that these two individuals were affected
with not one but two diseases one was
middle syndrome and the other one was a
different effect affecting the hearing
and so out of those four candidate genes
- and that being correct and if we were
to repeat exactly the same analysis
today we'll find only those two come to
the jeans because databases of knowledge
have improved since then so from there
from that initial stage having one
family with four people over the years
in our team we extended this a kind'
line of work and we started accumulating
hundreds of families thousands of people
that we had coach genome sequence access
for a variety of different phenotypes of
interest in different diseases and then
through a fantastic collaboration with
ANOVA
medical system so we obtained access to
many many more thousands of whole genome
sequences and this isn't as you can
imagine logistically a very difficult
problem to handle all those genomes
another analyze all the data in a
meaningful way one of the products that
we created was a database of all the
known variants so initially the question
was have we ever seen a specific variant
before and then at some point who
accumulated so many genomes with so many
variants observing them that the more
meaningful question became how
frequently have we seen this variant in
the population so this covered databases
eventually reached the point of having
13,000 all genome sequences and
significantly more excellent sequences
not just for more data for but also from
public resources very importantly among
them of course is in the thousand
genomes data set which is called the
thousand genomes and in reality has
2,500 individuals in it so ii imagine
again 13,000 individuals with whole
genome sequence that's a very
significant challenge if you want to do
for example comparisons of everybody
gets to everybody else and that since
then actually became like a small
problem because in recent times there's
been a whole series of announcements of
you know sequencing 10,000 genomes a
thousand genes per month people are
talking about million genomes Venter and
declaring this call to seek 100 million
genomes so you can imagine the amount of
genomic information about individual
genomes is going to explode it is
already expanding very very fast and
that definitely requires tools and
methods for analyzing all the state in a
very very efficient way so one a very
basic question that we have to think
about first is so what does one usually
do with one genome or with multiple
genomes
so very intuitively if one gets one
genome phone person
one wants to start by doing some QC and
my one might want to make an assessment
of what is a likely population of origin
of this person or populations of origins
if the person is not mixed then one
wants to recognize variation affecting
all the different possible elements in
the genome including protein coding
transcripts or non-protein coding
transcripts then finally of course one
wants to interpret all this variation in
the context of the genome itself and in
with integration with other omics types
and trace all the way from this variant
to the actual phenotype of started in
the person but but then that's very
different from what one usually wants to
do when taking more than one gene so say
for example we have two genomes or two
VCF files representing genomes of two
people so first of all the very first
question is maybe these are not two
people maybe it's the same person the
same individual so we need to be able to
recognize that these two genome
representations are actually talking
about the same person or we might
perhaps be able to recognize that these
are two closely related individuals or
maybe they are more distantly related
individuals in the same extended family
or maybe from the same population or
taken to an extreme we might recognize
that they're actually not from not even
from the same species so this all this
gradation of distance between two
individuals genomic distance we need a
metric for that and that's not a trivial
undertaking
then if extent is not to people not to
genomes but a whole set of genomes and
here I'm very schematically representing
every genome with this small sets of
squiggles and circles and those among
you with the sharp eyes you might notice
that two of this squiggles and circles
are identical so even for our eyes
that's difficult to capture that
immediately so you see all these
squiggles here and it probably doesn't
jump to your eyes in the
the two sets of these are identical and
these are very very tiny simple
representations of data just think about
doing exactly the same thing with very
large complex data like whole genome
human genomes so again if we have a set
of genomes we might want to again
recognize repeated copies of the same
individual or very closely related
individuals in this genome set or more
importantly we might want to do all
agates or comparisons and derive the
kinship matrix so a matrix representing
the similarity between all possible
pairs of individuals in its data set or
even following that we might want to
observe what is the structure of this
population and identify significant
clusters among the entire data set so to
do all this we need to be able to
compare two genomes and the question
then is what is involved in comparing
two genomes so let's take a possible
realistic example so you just had your
genome sequence
congratulations and your genome sequence
using some variation of Illumina
technology and you just received a large
VCF file that was pitches it and indexed
using zabbix and your genomes
represented using numbers 1 through 22
X&Y for the chromosomes and it's one
base that set itself as whole series of
technical things about how the geums
represented and also very importantly it
is represented relative to the most
recent version of the reference genome
but then for whatever reason we want to
compare your kingdom to my channel and I
had my genome sequence some time ago by
Complete Genomics different technology
it came represented in a non-standard
format called the master bar as
compressed in a different way that
chromosome names are different has both
0 and white one base representations of
the variants and and it's represented
relative to a different reference so how
do we compare this I mean some of these
things are relatively easy to tackle so
different file format that's just a
matter of parsing
different compression is trivial but
then some things are much more difficult
so for example the fact that we're
talking about different references is a
significant problem so these are just
this is just one example of a
combination of different issues and more
generally speaking there is a whole
variety of different formats in which
the genome could be represented again
many different technologies with their
different different quirks and
specificities and many different ways of
representing the volumes themselves zero
based one based different names for the
chromosomes etc and most importantly
again different versions of the
reference now why is that important
from one version for reference to the
next many things can change so there is
usually a small amount of actual
sequence change but most importantly
there are caps in the reference that get
fixed
or some regions that were thought to be
separate regions suddenly they are
recognized to be in the same so and then
the structure of the sequence itself may
change by significantly and that leads
most importantly to the fact that the
coordinates of the same location our
intuition of the same location in the
genome might have very different
coordinates from one version to the next
so that means that if now I have one
genome represented relative to this
version here at the top gee grch37 and
then the same thing I represented
relative to the newer version for
reference in the same variant located in
the two genomes will have different
coordinates so the way we thought that
is by recognizing but even if we have
the same set of variants with very
different coordinates the distance
between consecutive areas is pretty much
invariant so here and there there's
going to be some minor changes but since
the most important change from one
reference to another is relocating
things as a block then two pairs of
consecutive single local variants but
most of the time I'm going to preserve
the same distance so with that insight
we started developing this method in
which we take again the list of single
nucleotide variants expressed relative
to a specific reference
and that representation again has the
chromosome they coordinate that might
change sometimes even the chromosome
might change and then the reference
allele and the alternate allele and we
realize that if we take all this complex
information we can simplify it by taking
every pair of consecutive variants and
just describe that by the distance
between them then we can take the
reference in the alternate allele of the
two variants and use that as a key so
this is a pretty significant
simplification of the data and you might
notice that it's not just the coordinate
changes that we solved in this new
representation even the chromosome is
not named so it doesn't matter what you
call the chrome so you can grow the CHR
or not of you use some other identifiers
even in some chunk of sequence was
recognized to not actually healthy
nation chromosome 19 which was in some
other chromosome when it's red relegated
there then that series of variants in
that second segment of sequence is going
to be recognizable even though it was
moved from across into the other so once
we have this idea of transforming single
of the variants into pairs of them we
can try encoding them in a way that can
be easily compared between different
individuals there is one additional
important thing to keep in mind once we
talk about pairs of consecutive variants
there are some interesting effects that
depend on technology so here for example
a distribution of how frequently we
observe two variants at the distance of
the zero meaning during consecutive
nucleotides or a distance of one two
it's three etc and we see that between
these two technologies aluminum Complete
Genomics there is a massive difference
especially for very very short distance
and the reason for that is that
Complete Genomics their own pipeline the
pipeline that theyíve created for
analyzing the raw data whenever they
recognized two variants that are very
near to each other in same appetite
they're going to represent that as in
multi nucleotide change on the other
hand the most under resume in a pipeline
still to specify each of those variances
in the beam in the pen
the felt so that's why the Illumina
pipeline is going to have the very high
frequency of two single local variants
the distance of zero or one
when epigenomics has very few of those
so we take these two insights together
the fact we can simplify the
representation by distances and the
characteristics of the variants in terms
of reference node or continent allele
and this differences in technologies so
here's an overview essentially a big
overview of the entire method that we
created in which we start again from
this classic representation of variances
chromosome position reference an
alternate a deal-making as I said before
we just take the difference between the
two positions at the distance and that's
going to go into this initial table so
that's the distance between the two
variants and then the quality or the
what is the reference and what is the
alternate allele those four letters
become what we call the key in this case
the GATC key and we simply now the one
to that very very long table as I
mentioned in the previous slide we
recognized at the beginning of that
table is going to be all kinds of
Technology effects so we put those aside
and then the entire remaining section of
the table which could be very very long
we applied a module function with some
parameter L and using that module
function we can simplify all that
representation of entire genome into
what we call the raw fingerprint which
is simply a series of counts how many
times we observe a specific combination
of distance modulo this parameter L and
those positions the specific key of
which are reference alleles and which
are the alternate alleles of the two
variants
now if you do the combinations there's a
hundred forty-four possible keys because
there are four possible reference
alleles and three possible alternate
alleles in one variant and there's two
of those it's twelve eight 1244 possible
combinations and again another important
bit of insight from
genome biology is that since each of
this variant originated as a mutation in
some individual there is going to be a
very significant difference between the
frequencies of the different possible
mutations so some of these mutations are
transition with mutations which are much
more common than the transversion ones
so for example at AG mutate into an a is
much more common than a gene you're
taking to its seen now and that's what
leads to this intrinsic structure to the
Rho fingerprint table in this case for
red represents much more frequent and
blue is less frequent so we created a
very simple internal memorization
procedure that takes a takes care of all
that structure and this is a
representation here of the normalized
fingerprint which can then be directly
used for comparison for indexing and for
the population structure as I will show
in the next slides so one thing I want
to stress here is this is a really
really simple algorithm that has a whole
series of advantages some of them I
already mentioned that you don't need to
pay attention to which reference were
using in which way you represented the
numbers or the chromosome positions so
here I want to contrast the most under
way of doing this with our new method
using the fingerprints so as you can see
on the left side started from a genome
VCF the typical method for being able to
compare two genomes starts by doing
quite significant parsing you need to
pay attention to many many different
aspects of that of each VCF record then
you need to pay attention to the
chromosome identifiers in numerical
representation again very important
Indian to use --lift / or some other
tool to change one of those two genomes
to the the same reference as the other
otherwise you cannot compare there is
differences in which variants themselves
are represented and in to normalize that
eventually after a lot of complicated
work you end up having this harmonized
VCF format and then you need to
Alti much much invariance between the
two genomes and finally you're able to
compare for example using some Jaccard
similarity this for distance on the
other hand when you use that you know
fingerprinting method the parsing itself
is much more simplified because we only
need to pay attention to essentially the
column with the coordinate of the the
variant and the actual genotype sorry
not even the genotype the reference on
the alternate alleles and the
computational fingerprint itself is is a
very very efficient process that yields
the genome fingerprint which is a tiny
matrix of numbers and by taking two such
matrices and simply doing the Spearman
correlation that gives us directly a
metric of similarity between two genomes
so to give an example of this here's how
to compare two fingerprints you we take
this matrix and we serialize it into a
long factor and then we simply compute a
Spearman correlation between those two
vectors and that's it so here's an
example of a family tree or mother
following child and as you can see here
if I were to take the kingdom of the
father as the fingerprint correlated
with itself by definition it's going to
have a correlation of 1 then the both
parents each of them are highly
correlated with their child and since
these two parents are from the same
population there's also a pretty
significant correlation between their
genome fingerprints and now in this case
the father had this in the genome
sequence using another technology and
again it's a very very high correlation
between the Geno fingerprints obtained
for the same person is in two different
technologies right here point 75 or
higher in practice it's much higher than
that I mentioned before that there is
one important parameter in our method
that
rahmatullahu uses in modular so what
happens if we change that parameter and
here it's yet another benefit of this
method in which you can find human with
with that parameter whether you want to
have a smaller or larger fingerprint
which has all kinds of
effects on this obviously the smaller
the number L the smaller the resulted
fingerprints and the analysis is going
to be faster on the other hand if you
want more precise analysis you can
choose to have a longer parameter L or
longer fingerprint size and
interestingly if we take this to an
extreme the question could be for
example what happens if we use a value
of 2 as the parameter L and in that case
that actually creates what we call the
binary fingerprint so instead of using
modulo essentially we're asking for
every position is it an odd or even
number and that translates the entire
fingerprint into this binary string of
just 144 bits so just think about the
amazing compression that kills and that
still enables us to compare two genomes
with only 144 bits representing each of
them so here's one example of the test
that we did for to see whether this
analysis works so here's the big family
with lots of individuals in many many
different nuclear families inside so as
you can see lots of quartets here in
interlace with each other we sequence
the whole genome 435 of these
individuals represented here in green
and as you can imagine there is a very
large number of interesting pairwise
relationships here lots of seed pairs
lots of parent-child pairs have even a
couple of half siblings
there's plenty of uncles and aunts
grandparents all relationships cousins
second cousins etc so for each of these
different levels we compute and
aggregate all the similarities between
all the individuals in those levels of
similarity and here's a graph
representing the correlation that we
observe the average correlation for each
of those pairs as a function of the
fingerprint length all that parameter L
that I mentioned before and as you can
see beyond the certain amount of noise
was expected for very very short finger
prints with our less informative
past a certain value in this case
appears to be 20 it becomes very stable
so which means that it almost doesn't
matter after that value which parameter
use for the fingerprint length you're
going to create very clear separation
between whether to individuals or
siblings or if their grandparent
grandchild or cousins they get a very
very natural intuitive gradation here of
more closely related it's higher
correlation between two individuals now
to put this in context again if we talk
about sequencing the same genome twice
then we expect them to be in the two
representations of the genome for the
same person to be very very highly
correlated in our experience it's again
above 0.75 or 0.8 and if I were to
intuit the same analysts in the same
genome exactly since the method is
deterministic is going to be a
correlation of 1 they're going in the
other direction if we're talking about
individuals from different populations
and then the correlations are going to
be lower
somewhere between point 2 1 point 4 and
of course different species are not
going to be correlated at all now the
method is very robust in our experience
we try the whole variety of tests so
here for example one simulation that we
did in which we took a genome we
computed a fingerprint and then we
started simulating missing data so we
simulated what would happen if we ignore
10% of the variants in the genome 20%
etcetera etcetera
as you can see here the correlation
between the resulting fingerprint and
the fingerprint of the complete genome
pretty much the case linearly at first
as a function of the fraction of missing
data and if we remember that two copies
of the of the genome of the same person
are correlated 0.75 over 0.8 or above
then we can see here the method is
robust to approximately 30% missing late
which is quite impressive
so that's four
comparing to individuals what about
comparing being individuals for example
for reconstruction reconstruction of
population structure so here's again the
very complicated procedure one is to do
if one wants to reconstruct population
structure using standard methods as I
mentioned going from the genome VCF to
harmonize VCF once you harmonized many
many genomes you can combine them into
multi sample VCF file and then you need
to do whole series of steps again
requiring quite a bit of computation and
very significant knowledge about
population structure and genome
structure which will change from one
species to another so you need to do
work on filtering from reliable variants
or regions in the genome that are less
reliable you need to select variants by
real frequency and take care of linkage
disequilibrium between variants and
finally in to select some suitable size
subset of a variants because the
computation is going to be so large your
computer might run out of memory for
exam so finally once you did all that
then you can do a PCA analysis or Disney
or some other ordination method to
reconstruct the population and here you
can see one example from the thousand
genomes data set again 2,500 individuals
doing all this very complicated work to
select the order 300 million a second
two thousand the variance snips and
finally you get this visualization of
the population structure of humans so
how does it work with the genome
fingerprints instead of that as I
mentioned before very simplified parsing
and efficient computation of
fingerprints which has to be done only
once per person and we have a collection
of Geno fingerprints so to compute or
reconstruct a population structure all
we have to do is simply combine all
those fingerprints into one big table
and again like before each fingerprint
is a matrix of numbers we see realizes
that into a vector now we just put all
those factors into a simple simple table
that is immediately a perfect substrate
for PCA or Disney or other such methods
so again it's a very very simplified
method for doing this without requiring
any specialized knowledge of the genome
structure or the population structure in
advance so here's an example of what it
looks like again the upper left we can
see the same results in two in the
standard method selecting the variance
and the upper right is the result that
we get of reconstructing the human
population with this much simplified
method using the genome fingerprints now
L of 120 is pretty high quality
fingerprints and you can see the results
are again not as sharp as with the
standard method but the result is very
very comparable and most importantly the
principal components that we get are
exactly the same as in the original
analysis and of course it's much simpler
and much faster pretty much at every
level of the analysis including the PCI
itself is much more efficient if we do
the same analysis using somewhat lower
quality fingerprint of length hundred
twenty it's again much faster result is
again not as high quality as before but
it gives you a pretty clear indication
you can still identify whether
individual comes from it maybe even
population or or the other and and here
you see an example doing kissed me again
on the same smaller fingerprints and you
can see that they can then indeed
segregate the populations pretty well so
all that is about human genomes and I
can assure that if I have a little bit
of knowledge about human genome
structure and population structure I
definitely don't know anything about
sheep genomes so as as a test of whether
its methods generalizable we simply
downloaded a whole set of 453 individual
sheep genomes and we run them through
the exact same pipeline computed the
fingerprints indeed within five minutes
we already have this visualization PCI
of the structure of their sheep
population again the PCI was
super efficient just 15 seconds to
compute
and again just like with sheep like a
very little knowledge at all of plant
genome structure and nevertheless we can
do exactly the same analysis and very
very efficiently compute fingerprints
for all these 3,000 Bryce genomes that
were made public a couple of years ago
and very efficiently again Ric abstract
population structure of different rice
strains so now that we mentioned
populations there is another further
step that we can do beyond the
normalization of the genome itself of a
gene or fingerprint we can also do this
extra step of adjusting a genome to a
population so it is called earlier how
we compute the raw fingerprints on okay
how we do this internal motivation once
we recognize that the GM represents a
person coming from specific population
we can actually subtract the centroid of
that population and get an adjusted
fingerprint which again takes into
account the population structure itself
and this actually improves our ability
to compare it Pierce's in individuals to
for example fine cryptic relationships
so here's an analysis of again thousand
genomes dataset 2,500 individuals now
the way this data set was uncertain they
were not supposed to be close
relationships between among people in
the data set nevertheless our method can
recognize there the series of pairs of
siblings and some burdens offspring of
relationships and whole series of
cousins and one killer relationship
meaning uncles and even one pair of half
siblings now this is not exactly new
knowledge this is confirming prior
observations using other other methods
but this is to show that indeed our
method is able to do that and it also
has the advantage of being able to
distinguish it in current off-screen
relationships and full siblings now
here's a couple of examples of was what
this looks like in in practice so as I
said we meant we observed some parents
after relationship
and here's three individuals from the
thousand genome data set the two parents
on the child and not only that but there
is also another person a cousin of of
the father which is obviously also
related to the child here we can
recognize is very efficiently using
these computations on the chain of
fingerprints and here's another case in
which there's a couple of brothers and
the whole network of cousins in the same
dataset so again this was not supposed
to be there according to the original
goal of the way the data were
constructed but nevertheless it can be
found very efficiently in using this
method so I mentioned before that it's
also important to be able to do all
against all comparisons to identify this
kind of structure or here in structure
and for other purposes as well including
to support gos analysis so again this is
a very complex series of steps that one
is to do to reach multi sample VCF and
then there's a few more transformations
to bring it into a standard link format
and then you can use that to compute the
kinship matrix again the question is how
can we do this more efficiently using
fingerprints so going from the
fingerprints we divide we devise a
method for serializing them into a
binary format that can then be very
inefficiently compared so create a
database of binary structured in
fingerprints then we can very
conveniently compare to compute this
finger this is a kinship matrix and just
to give an idea of the speed of that
obviously going to depend on the size of
a fingerprint on this parameter Dell but
in practice what it means we can do all
against all comparisons of the thousand
genomes dataset in pretty much one
minute high resolution or 11 seconds if
we use smaller fingerprints and just to
stress of this is on one CPU this is
also trivially parallelizable so in
principle that can be done much faster
some of you might want to
might be think at the moment yes but
this is faster but is still quadratic so
if we are talking about 21 microseconds
per comparison for those fingerprint
sizes if we now want to compare a
million genomes or two or against all
but that's going to come and take a
significant fraction of a year one one
CPU so even though this fingerprint
comparison since I'd like to say there
light speed that's too slow we need to
go to ludicrous B so we started
developing a method in which we can take
again advantage of the structure of the
fingerprints as a matrix of numbers and
here's one idea of a method that we have
evaluated in which we can look at this
matrix and identify extreme values and
then we can use those to create a in an
index of their fingerprints so again we
can take a large data set of
fingerprints of genomes create this
index and then using that index we can
actually query much faster to identify
likely pairs of correlated genomes for
similar genomes and in one first test
that we did instead of those 122 days we
will have taken to compare all against
all for one million genomes our
extrapolation it would take us 26
minutes again on one CPU so with
suitable for analyzation which will be
possible to do 1 million genomes in a
very very comfortable amount of time so
as you can see doing analysis of gene a
fingerprint is not just easy but also
very very efficient I also want to
mention how efficient in size is a
fingerprint start so going back to the
first queue and the bound format and the
VCF and there's also a genome VCF which
is more verbose and more informative
than VCF and you can see here typical
sizes of these different representations
of a genome now using genome
fingerprints we can represent these
genomes in much smaller file sizes which
again contributes to speed
and the convenience of analysis and
here's an important distinction between
working with VCF format or fingerprints
with a VCF as I mentioned from the
beginning you want to be able to compare
the genomes which you can do with the
fingerprints as well with your scope can
annotate the genomes and go all the way
to interpretation and one important
thing is that you cannot reconstruct a
whole genome VCF from the fingerprint
it's in massively lossy transformation
so one could think about that is the
disadvantage so I can only compare them
but I also want to interpret the genomes
but one can turn that upside down and
say well maybe that's actually an
advantage because if for example as I
said before you just have your genome
sequence that you want to know how
similar the two of us are and you're
willing to share with me information to
do that computation but maybe you're not
so happy about sharing with me your
whole genome data because I might be
able to compute whether you're going to
what do you have a high propensity for
developing some disease maybe you're
going to develop Parkinson's or have a
high propensity for for developing some
other phenotype that you don't want the
world to know about so the ability to
separate between these two things is
actually a benefit in the sense that we
can do all kinds of genome analytics
that are based on comparison without at
the same time revealing all that rich
information that can be used to
interpret the genome so it's essentially
a different type of privacy preservation
that is beyond the classical problem or
the classical world that people have
about reagent if occasionally nomes you
can interpret genomes use in the
original files once he uses for quality
sensitive hashing method that we call
gene or fingerprints so once you compute
the gene your fingerprint you can
compare them super fast very
conveniently
but you cannot go back you cannot
reconstruct the genome and you cannot
interpret
directly from the genome fingerprint so
one other thing I wanted to mention
again the importance of comparing
genomes to make sure whether it's the
same person or related or to reconstruct
population structure that goes back
again to this idea that it's important
for us to have a metric or similarity
for doing a whole variety of different
analysis and I hope I demonstrated that
this is not feasible or we can do all
this analysis that could be done using
standard methods but now it's much
easier much faster I know this opens up
a whole variety of other implementation
or other use cases and I'm going to
mention a couple of them so first of all
this is kind of a trivial one where I
can say well if we have already a large
database of genomes and ever-growing
database of genomes and we just sequence
another genome have we seen it before is
it part of our database so this is again
something that could be done but now
it's trivial to do and again I want to
mention the fact that now we can do this
even through a variable if you wish so
the database might be in one location
the genome is in a different location
and they can be compared to make sure
whether the genome is part of the data
set or not without information ever
going from one side to the other and
then even more interestingly now we can
compare sets of genomes so equals for
example think about here's one set of
genomes that were included in one study
and here's the other set of genomes was
in a different study now you want to
merge these two studies or you want to
do meta-analysis and it's very important
for you to know that well subsets of
Latinos are actually the same people so
if you don't pay attention to that you
definitely might have all kinds of
spurious results and you might be misled
by the another there is also the
meta-analysis and again the same idea
that two researchers might have their
own data sets and they might not be
allowed by organs of regulatory reasons
to share the completely
data and it's also very very cumbersome
to share big amount of genome data
through the internet so in this case
they can actually do some kind of
matchmaking to say do we share the same
gene or gene data sets and distinct even
more interesting than that that's the
post for example that the genomes on the
left side are cases that one researcher
has and they need controls they need to
identify suitable controls and another
researcher says well here I have a data
set of a big data set of genomes that
you could potentially use as controls so
this method of fingerprints actually
allows you to identify for each case a
optimally matched suitable control so
it's beyond saying are these people from
the same population I can actually
identify the closest match in the other
data set or it could even go even beyond
that and try to optimize the similarity
between each pair of matched case of
controls so that something is very very
difficult to do with existing methods
but now even using the Geno fingerprints
and the ease of comparing them that
becomes a feasible application so all
that was about T no fingerprints and as
I mentioned we start with standard
representation of the VCF that's not the
only format that exists out there for
doing analysis of genome or genetic data
very important other format that exists
based on muslin different technology is
the gene type format in which for
example companies like 23andme and
ancestry DNA they take DNA samples and
they put them on a microarray and by
hybridization not by sequencing they
obtain statements about this position
the reference here's the genotype of the
person so this is a somewhat different
data type because when one on the one
side each of this violence is actually
precisely identified using an RS ID and
identifier from the
database and on the other hand there's
also statements about genotypes not
about observed variance relative to a
reference so here statement this ggot
see here that might be the reference
allele and that statement is present
here in this format which would not have
been represented in a VCF so we created
also a version of our fingerprinting
method that works on genotypes I'll call
this August July fingerprints and here's
one interesting result of what one can
do again this is a reconstruction or
this reconstruction of the population
structure of humans based on the
thousand genomes data set which we
simulated as if 23andme had another is
each of them using two different
versions of the chip which have
different numbers of variants and you
can see here in this results that PC one
versus PC two of this analysis is not
confounded by the size of the array so
the genotype in the Gentile fingerprint
fingerprinting method is robust to
certain differences only when you go to
BC 3 in a connection distinguish between
the two and here you can see the work
with similarities between the same
person using the two for months to the
sizes of the array and they are much
different from the relationship you get
among closely related or disability
related individuals so I covered all
these different aspects of why we need
the genome fingerprints and the bottom
line is essentially to scale up analysis
on a very complex representation of data
of data
genome data's complex both in
intrinsically and the way it is
represented the way that when they work
is through a locality sensitive hashing
method which I didn't cover in detail
but that's the class of algorithms that
were using and we have pretty important
characteristics again they're compact
they're very robust to variations in the
data they are very efficient they need
to be computed only once that's also a
very significant difference compared to
the need to take to look into the entire
you know every time
with comparison and again they are
one-way compression of the data which
preserves privacy in a certain way so
again the enable is to simplify a very
complex task scaling them up and
preserve privacy and I claim that this
is also going to help democratize genome
analytics where people are going to more
people are going to have their own
personal genome sequence and they're
going to want to compare them to the
genome solar people and participate in
studies so what comes next so the next
thing that we are very very excited
about is this idea of fingerprinting
semi structured data and I'm going to
very very briefly describe that so the
idea is that if you think about
different levels of data there is
structured data and genomes are
differently that somos traditional data
sources and relational databases or
structured data and there's most of the
time pretty well defined methods for
analyzing that but then there is semi
structured data using flexible schemas
like XML and JSON and that's a very
significant amount of big data these
days comes in that format and finally is
going to be also instructed on
structured data like free text and
images that are much harder to compare
so we developed a method the first
version of a method for analyzing semi
structured data using again the
fingerprinting through locality
sensitive hashing and this method has
the variety of advantages that also
apply we can also apply the same method
to speed up the analysis of structured
data we already have some preliminary
tests on completely unstructured data
using a very similar method so I'm just
going to show one example of one thing
that we did using this so we took a set
of about a thousand simulated patient
records in modern fire format and using
the state of fingerprinting methods that
we recently published as a preprint we
could very easily compare all these
thousand plus complex electronic health
records in JSON format
very similar to the genome fingerprints
will reduce them to a fingerprint and
then we very easily use some ordination
method in this case again ECA to
recognize data recognize structure in
the cohort and as you can see from this
very schematic color in using different
turns so here is a cluster of people
that have all kinds of pregnancy related
terms in the in the electronic health
record here in red you can see likely
children that have mostly vaccinations
related terms here's a cluster of people
that are they have in their simulated
record death certification and here's
another class two people that were
presumably in sent to the hospital for
some reason and were sent to do some
basic metabolic panel so again this is a
very very informative analysis of this
cohort of electronic health records
which are complex but there come their
comparison became really simplified
using this method and without a will
finish I want to thank people nor team
particularly max Robinson brilliant
mathematician who helped me developed
the basic methodology of the
fingerprinting Denise Malden has been a
software engineer in our team and
supported us a lot with that and the
conch Shah Baba who is a brilliant
student amazing fast learner and she
participated in developing some of these
advanced applications of the method I
also wish to thank our funders
particularly the big data for Discovery
Science Center from NIH and will with
that I will take any questions
starla that was really fantastic I think
this is really exciting kind of
methodology for taking big data making
it compact enough to do a lot of very
common statistical comparisons with and
really make it tractable for a wide
range of applications in biomedical
science
I want to encourage we have a few
minutes left if there are any questions
encourage the audience members to submit
them by the little question submission
system in the meantime Gustavo you'd
mentioned that the fingerprinting method
once you've taken a full genome and you
compressed it down to a fingerprint that
it's not reversible I'd be curious if
its locality preserving could you not
reverse it and get a sense of location
if you had a particular statistical
result that one could then remap at
least into a position and then one could
then refer that position back to the
whole genome so the sense of locality
preserving is the word locality in this
context is a bit confusing what that
means is that the similarity between two
genomes is going to be preserved in the
fingerprint so if two genomes are
similar or if you think about the
population of genomes the location of
one genome in that space is preserved ok
the distance between two genomes in that
similarity space that is like this I see
I see
not the locations of the variants
locations of variants they get used for
computation but they get completely
innocent so the system intentionally has
a very high level of collision between
different bits of information that go
the flow into the fingerprint I see I
see are there any other applications
that you see oops that use excuse me did
you see fingerprinting being applied to
that perhaps you didn't get a chance to
cover yes there's many many different
applications different levels of
complexity of describing it but again
one one application that I envision is
again having a researcher that says I
have a dataset here I have a set of
cases and I want to identify controls
suitable control so so if you think
about the centralized database of
fingerprints that anyone can query
and that database can help you as a
matchmaker it can tell you based on the
fingerprints of the genomes that you're
interested I recommend that you contact
this other researcher and that person
would be kind of your ideal partner for
doing this study that's one kind of
application somewhat similar to what I
described earlier another kind of
application that we have started working
on that's that's what the culture was
working on is the concept that if you
think about genome-wide Association
studies that have very very strong
tendency to be done on European
populations Caucasian populations and
based on the results of the genome-wide
Association studies you can compute
polygenic risk scores for individuals so
because of that bias population bias in
the population the polygenic risk scores
there are going to be more appropriate
for the same population on which they
were trained they're going to be much
less relevant to other populations which
introduces all kinds of biases so we
started working on a method in which you
can use the fingerprints to dynamically
select the population of relevant people
or similar people and then you can model
the polygenic risk or computed for one
person or relative to the similar people
okay so it's a way of adjusting for for
the population structure in a completely
dynamic way without having predefined
populations so that's a a kind of
methodology of application of the
fingerprints that were very very excited
about that sounds really interesting so
are you looking for collaborators or
definitely looking for collaborators
anyone who has ideas for how to improve
the methods or has other similar data
types or other ideas of things that
could be analyzed using this kind of
methodology and again the kind of the
basic idea is whenever you have complex
objects in this case could be a genome
or could be an EHR so complex objects
that are hard to compare and you have
lots of them so this kind of methodology
is
30 powerful for that scenario well this
sounds really fantastic and this is a
very exciting approach to dealing with
large-scale data and applying data
science methodologies to it for a wide
range of biomedical applications I
encourage anybody who's listening to
visit the websites which are listed down
at the bottom of the Gustavo's screen
and I see that we've reached the top of
the hour and I want to once again thank
you give my thanks to Gustavo glutes
Minh from the Systems Institute for
systems biology in Seattle I want to
thank everybody for joining us today and
have a great weekend and we'll see you
next time thanks again Gustavo thank you